about you and your opinions if you're
thinking about it we're talking about it
it's all about me that's a joke
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
I am Rosanna Lockwood uncensored tonight
vegan campaigners are calling for Prince
William to incentivize the plant-powered
revolution as part of his Earth shot
prize but what will happen to rural jobs
in this Brave new green World we've got
best-selling vegan chefs the Bosch boys
they'll be going head-to-head with one
of the nation's favorite farmers
Disney's latest Snow White says her
version doesn't need some weird Prince
Charming stalking her and she's getting
roasted for that online so should modern
fairy tales leave feminism to the real
world
and he was the interviewer to the Stars
lined up to talk to Sir Michael
Parkinson will be paying her own tribute
to that true giant of British television
[Music]
live from the news building in London
this is Piers Morgan uncensored with
Rosanna Lockwood good evening welcome to
Piers morganland center with me Rosanna
Lockard once again in the chair for
peers and I want to start the show
tonight by addressing my interview with
graham Linehan last night it went out
live but we aren't repeating it and
that's not because of censorship not
because we're seeking to de-platform
anyone one of the reasons for talk TV's
existence is to hear from all sides of
the argument we don't hide from
sensitive topics we believe in free
speech we relish robust debate but it's
also important for us to stay within the
parameters of tried and trusted
principles around broadcasting now
Others May seek to deliberately abuse or
undermine those rules we don't we view
what we do coming into your home each
and every day is a privilege and we take
that responsibility very seriously and
we'll continue to do so now I have also
received a great deal of personal abuse
across social media over the past 24
hours so there's a few things I'd like
to make clear
I'm a journalist but of course I have my
own deeply felt personal views and they
don't necessarily chime with everyone I
interview or even everyone I work with
here at talk TV just ask peers or pretty
much anyone else but no one here has
ever tried to influence the way I work
no one's tried to censor my thoughts on
my beliefs in fact they've only ever
given me free reign to be who I am
uncensored if you will I'm in this chair
doing exactly that so I'll continue to
challenge I'm going to continue to call
that hypocrisy bullying misinformation
wherever or whenever I see it so let's
keep debating let's keep discussing
these issues big or small that really
matter to the world but for Pretty State
let's keep it civilized
wow
let's move to some other more important
stuff going on in the world for that I'm
joined by my Thursday night politics
pack please say talk TV contributor
Paula and Adrian joins us talk TV's
International editor Isabel oakshot and
talk TV presenter Richard Tice all three
of you good to see you hello good
evening and we've got some pretty chunky
topics to get into can I say for once
the Saudi Crown Prince visit to the
United Kingdom Muhammad bin Salman of
course now he is due to visit Downing
Street says Rishi sunak has shared a
call with him look forward to meeting in
person at the earliest possible
opportunity now we've known about this
visit for some months of course it
raises debate and questions every time
because of Saudi Arabia's human rights
record very different approach to
society than our own but we are
necessarily reliant on them for a number
of reasons Paula do you think it's right
to all out the red carpet so no I don't
I'm deeply Disturbed and I'm deeply
Disturbed let me make this clear at a
political level because do I love Dubai
yes I do would you want to call me a
hypocrite whilst I sit there on my sun
lounger yes you would but I'm not
talking about the Emirates I'm not
talking about the people of Dubai I'm
talking about a ruler of a kingdom who
the FBI have told us I just yeah sorry
Paul I think we've got a bit of a
confusion here because we're talking
about Saudi
forgive me
no you haven't I was just about to tell
you so they're very very different it's
my last day before I go
to Dubai on holiday yeah I'm not but
this is where I am
so it doesn't really pick up on that but
no question you probably feel even more
strongly
um about whether or not the leader of
Saudi should come than than UAE leaders
because they are very very different
regimes and people feel deeply about
this and of course they do because some
of the human rights atrocities in Saudi
are truly horrific you know we will all
remember the khashoggi murder which sent
shock waves around the world clear links
with the leadership there how the FBI
report tells us however however that was
many years ago that is not to say that
there are not still serious human rights
abuses in Saudi they are still you know
their form of Justice particularly uh
outside reality many many years ago
so let me let me continue about why I I
think that the government the UK
government is doing the right thing here
um we are as you said dependent on Saudi
but much more importantly Saudi is
modernizing under mbs's leadership huge
changes are taking place it's not right
across the country but there are big
Visions for Saudi under their Vision
2030 thing they've got huge plans to
change and on a day-to-day basis things
are dramatically improving so for
example the integration of women in
society also we need them you know they
are one of our biggest defense export
clients as it were so I think this is
the Isabella is putting it nicely but
she's talking about selling weapons
put it nicely that is one of our main
industries you know it contributes a
huge amount and in return for which also
we are reliant on their um their oil
they are a huge huge exporter to us and
that's absolutely critical and we're not
energy self-reliant we could be we
should be we're not there are very
important trading partner look all
countries make mistakes all leaders make
mistakes and and what happened with was
horrific but nevertheless we've made
terrible mistakes in the UK you know the
US has made terrible mistakes we have to
learn from them and we have to accept
them and then move on and I think that
actually this is the right thing to do
they are our most important Middle
Eastern partner and we're always going
to have differences but as Isabelle says
they are making progress and they are
modernizing and things happen at
different speeds I listen you've all
brought up some really important points
I used to be a Middle East based
journalist based in UE based in Dubai I
covered Saudi a lot I went to Saudi many
times I've seen the modernization
Isabel's talked about I was there the
day that women were allowed to drive
first time I visited I was wearing a
full a buyer in hijab the second time I
visited no no um hijab anymore I have
seen the changes that are taking place
but I've also seen the effects of 9.7
billion pounds worth of UK arms sent to
the Saudi Coalition the Saudi Arabians
are bombing Yemen uh frequently these
are all things that need to be factored
in when we think about our relationship
with them yes they are a petrol
exporting State oil exporting so we do
need them as well so there's a lot tied
up in this there's defense there's
energy there's morality oh I was just
going to add morality to that and social
injustice you know at what stage do we
start saying No thank you
to be honest do we roll out the red
carpet I'm not suggesting that we don't
talk to people we don't disagree with
you have to do that at a diplomatic
level you have to do that but the
question was should we be rolling out
the red carpet and the answer is yeah I
mean they would certainly roll out the
red carpet to us you know they are they
know how to do hospitality and some look
this is diplomacy you don't just
shabbily you know let them come in and
not have a proper ceremony if we're
going to do this we do it properly we do
roll out the red carpet everybody knows
the differences in the way that we
approach criminal justice and by the way
we don't dismember people we don't Stone
women for adultery but our own criminal
justice systems
their disgrace every week goes past
there are awful stories a terrible
miscarriage of justice that we carried a
big discussion on our um talk TV last
night so we you know we're not Saints
are we it's but it's correct that we're
not Saints but we don't abide by the
wrong do we we try to correct the wrong
well I think that I I think we're all
High Ground yeah I mean we you know you
talk about social injustice some of the
social injustices here in the UK I
suggest we focus on those yeah and um
walking down our country Richard
think of our own issues but I just think
this is a a really significant trading
partner they are modernizing and we can
help we can help bring them forward and
they will do things at their own pace
let's move on to another really thorny
and difficult geopolitical topic shall
we uh Ukraine and NATO so of course the
war drags on in Ukraine and everyone
wants to see the end of it but whenever
any brings up the idea of any kind of
piece being broken on the idea of
Ukraine sort of losing some of its land
to Russia it's a very sensitive issue
one that I don't agree with personally
but Stephen Jensen Chief of Staff to the
Secretary General Yen saltenberg so this
is all to do with NATO of course he said
in a meeting a few days ago he suggested
about this idea of surrendering
territory and then he's been lambasted
for that for even bringing it up
um ukrainians have reacted angrily to
that and they've since sort of walked
back on their comments because that is
pretty major isn't it coming from
somebody within NATO well it's major not
not only because of the the the the
suggestion you know what it would mean
to Ukraine but it's been suggested
before and the backlash that you know
the various different people who have
raised it before why are we even going
there anymore it's it you know president
zenski has made it very clear it is not
up for discussion the suggestion that
they could relinquish any of their
territory and why and why should they
and it's set in a very dangerous
president
um president as far as I'm concerned for
NATO to even be suggesting that that's a
possibility let's listen to president
zelenski saying this two Piers Morgan
will you ever contemplate
doing any kind of deal which involves
Ukraine giving up territory to Russia we
know we are not prepared to exchange or
trade the territory of the independent
state of Ukraine
we have no right for this first of all
we are the government because this land
belongs to Ukrainian people
I mean Isabel we can understand how
ukrainians feel about it certainly
absolutely
um and I think to put the remarks in
context and that's not to say they were
the right thing to say he was outlining
a number of scenarios at a think tank
event this wasn't some kind of
pronouncement of NATO policy at the
highest level he was saying here are
some scenarios under which this Dreadful
War might somehow come to the end but
it's not going to happen
um you know it's it's just as you said
president zielinski has made that very
clear
um in reality this war has gone on for a
lot longer really than people
um perhaps widely realized and I was out
in Ukraine in about 2018 at the front
line of what was already at War then but
a long War of Attrition and my concern
is that this just goes on in almost
indefinitely you know with both sides
refusing to to surrender effectively
um and so I guess the interesting part
of this is how does this come to an end
it's not going to end by the seeding of
substantial amount of territory no it's
not look let's move on and just talk
quickly about the World Cup shall we uh
lighten things up of course England
through to the final on Sunday with uh
they're going to be playing Spain and
Richard what do you make of the fact
that Prince of Wales is not going to be
going he's the president of the Football
Association he's not going to be flying
ice currently on holiday too far look
the reality is it's not going to change
the result is it and he's whatever he
does I mean he's going to be criticized
either way if he does go people will say
oh it's not sort of uh showing
leadership in terms of of the whole
climate debate if he doesn't go he he
can't win
um it doesn't give me a problem at all I
think they're doing amazingly well a
fantastic chance of winning a World Cup
and the ladies leading the way and
that's to be celebrated and wherever it
is he'll be watching it I think just
give him a break Piers has tweeted this
evening that he thinks uh the Prince of
Wales would go if it was the men's World
Cup final sugar that Paula absolutely
well there would have been a lot of a
bigger build up wouldn't there to be
fair and there would have been a lot
more advances you say that but you know
this is a this is something that happens
every four years he's the president of
the fa the date would have been penciled
in his diary this date is not going to
come as a surprise to him so the fact
that he's not there I think is
incredibly disappointed will the Lioness
will the lionesses do and one of those
things is the president of the fa is to
support footballers and he's not doing
that now will the lionesses be
disappointed no they won't I don't think
because they'll be used to it they'll be
used to be being disappointed by men
talking the talk and failing to walk the
wall I think peers is wrong actually I
don't think he would have gone if it was
the men's
that's my own thing you know he's a he's
a family man he's very do you think it's
a problem with Australia then just the
distance
Australia is a great country yeah but
you just you can't do everything in life
and he can't do everything and likewise
I wish you sooner I won't wish you soon
act to stay here and sort out the
challenges of this car yeah
well you get you know Globe trots up to
Scotland and the Jet and gets abuse for
that okay looking for an invite himself
maybe he's sort of trying to fill the
seats I think he's on a plane today but
maybe not to Australia look pack thank
you very much stay with us towards the
end of the show we'll be coming back to
you but uncensored next tonight Disney's
latest Snow White is being accused of
wanting to kill off the weird Prince
Charming we'll debate fairy tale
feminism next
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
Trump Mr President first lady Stormy
Daniels John Peterson welcome to all
these people protesting just don't get
it any of them don't isn't that slightly
patronizing
when you're going through the treatments
you have some tears God I'm such a softy
I'm not a performing monkey come on
Brian and it's something that really
hurt me because they doubt of my words
a woman is me a woman is somebody whose
breasts hang down to her stomach I
thought the marginalized we're supposed
to have the boys I've been a terrible
liar
you're being a Karen pass Morgan
kiss condoms to kiss caskets will get
you coming and we'll get you going I
think it's only room for one king man
now I'm saying
[Music]
bear is your reminder that you can vote
for kids Morgan uncensored in the
National Television Awards by going
online and having your say at
nationaltvawards.com or by scanning this
code on your screen now hold your phone
up to the screen and say you're taking a
picture and it will automatically take
you to that voting site peers is up for
a Gong the best TV interview and we all
know he would love to add to that trophy
collection so do get voting a few weeks
back you might remember Disney's new
Snow White hit the headlines for getting
rid of seven dwarfs and replacing them
with average sized magical creatures
peers and his guests at the time weren't
happy
behind the scenes pictures from Disney's
live-action remake of Snow White release
this weekend there appears to be a
sizable problem where are the dwarfs
these are rules made for actors of my
stature I can't go out for the Harrison
Ford or the George Clooney roles because
that's not for me right and now it's
taken away
it I don't feel that's right
well now that very same production has
caused controversy after the actress who
plays Snow White said this about Prince
Charming
in an interview Rachel Ziegler saying
the original cartoon came out in 1937
and very evidently so there is a big
focus on her love story with a guy
literally stalking her how weird well we
have a different approach to what a lot
of people will assume is a love story
because we cast a guy in the movie but
it's really not about the love story at
all which is really really wonderful
well there has been inevitable backlash
online fans accusing Disney of inserting
unnecessary feminism into classic fairy
tales joining me now to debate this is
the host of Tommy Lauren as Fearless on
outkick Tommy Lauren hi Tommy I am from
New York the brand marketing consumer
expert and founder and Chief soothsayer
from sooth Ian bear once again great to
see you both uh Atomic I'll give you a
take on this uh Disney just messing with
the classics
yeah they certainly are now listen if
Disney wants to make more woke films
that tank at the box office they are
more than welcome to do that but maybe
think of an original idea maybe not
destroy a classic from my childhood and
put an actress in there that not only
hates the plot in the storyline of the
movie She's in but also seemingly hates
Snow White the character herself I mean
that's one interview clip that you read
the quote from but she's gone on to talk
about this film numerous times how she
once thought Snow White was creepy she
doesn't like the prince she thinks she
should get paid more because she has to
wear that dress you should get paid for
streaming for every hour she has to wear
the dress I mean talk about biting the
hand that feeds you not only are you
being casted in a classic film to remake
it but you don't seemingly like your own
character so she comes off as an
insufferable whiny brat and that's why
people are so annoyed Beyond just them
inserting feminism I think we expect
that at this point but why do you have
to mess with a classic especially with
someone who doesn't even seem to like
her own character okay interesting I
hear your take on her and the interview
she's giving and the type of sort of the
way she's coming across but you say that
you're kind of used to feminism being
inserted into Disney movies now Ian it's
a smart marketing move isn't it
well any moves the smart marketing move
that resonates with the people who are
putting Revenue against your product
look the reality is Disney has been uh
doing very inclusive casting for decades
now go back to the 1980s and that's
really when they turned the corner and
that formula of damsels in distress got
replaced this with these more heroic uh
feminine characters beginning with Ariel
back then but certainly all the Disney
Princesses ever since have really been
triumphant females so it's not a shock
to see Disney pivot from you know 19th
century German Source material right the
something that they believe is going to
resonate with with the audience uh of
course you know people vote with their
wallets right it told me 19th century
German Source material can you really
blame Disney for wanting to call a
modern audience gen Z and yanga these
girls they think differently they act
differently they have different
aspirations in life
yeah it's okay to modernize things but
if you have such an issue with the
original fairy tale and the original
storyline maybe instead of remaking it
you just make a different movie I don't
think that's too much to ask for but
furthermore listen you can have female
characters that are empowered that do
great things that are that are heroines
I mean that's fantastic I don't think
anybody has an issue with it but you
don't have to disparage men in the
process you don't have to call Prince
Charming a stalker you don't have to say
that you could just eliminate him from
the whole movie I mean there is a space
where you can have strong females and
strong males it's called the real world
or you know at least some places it
still exists maybe only here in
Nashville Tennessee and others but it's
okay to do both and you don't have to
make men seem emasculated in puny to
make women seem strong and you don't
have to eliminate them all together as
this actress has actually suggested well
okay uh Ian what about the controversy
that this film has received online gee
it's clearly not coming from the young
women it's marketed in fact it seems to
be coming from a male demographic
well yeah well I I think it's
interesting that there's been so much
backlash where this is concerned yet not
really the same kind of backlash around
the Barbie movie which has certainly
taken a different point of view you know
most people who grew up with Barbie
dolls when you open that package it
didn't immediately start speaking out
against the patriarchy right yet yet the
Barbie movie we see today takes quite a
feminist stance and a more inclusive
stance than we've generally seen
associated with the character so you
know this is Disney's intellectual
property they can do what they want with
it people are going to choose to spend
their money on it or not it's it's not
really a matter of of moral judgment you
know entertainment and art is is created
to be received and appreciated by an
audience and this is Commercial Art this
isn't to hang in a museum it's going to
succeed or fail on that mirror and the
Barbie movie you brought up of course a
really fast grossing billion dollar
movie for a female director beating all
expectations and all that controversy
tell me I want to come back to you
because you made a really good point
there about strong men and strong women
why'd you have to crush one to have the
other and I was thinking about the James
Bond franchise you know there's often
this muted idea that women will suddenly
be stepping in to play Bond we've
obviously got a lot of female characters
in that now do you think that's been to
James Bond's detriment or do you think
it's been a success the way they've
modernized that
I think that the numbers will speak for
themselves on that and again when you
have a franchise that you have created
around a James Bond character who is a
strong male character you don't need to
go and then replace James Bond with a
female you can have other strong females
but what is this process now where it's
like in order to be inclusive you have
to completely destroy story lines
completely destroy franchises I don't
believe in that I don't think that
consumers believe in that either you
know there is a way to modernize things
there's a way to bring in inclusivity
and diversity but you don't have to
completely destroy the concept in order
to do that and that's why you know going
back to the Barbie movie I didn't have
an issue with the Barbie movie because
it's what I expected right I've always
looked at Barbie as a female empowerment
tool I thought it was a women by women
for women didn't see an issue with it
it's when they go and they try to monkey
with other things where it doesn't
belong that it just comes off as
disingenuous and the consumer I don't
think they're gonna buy it I don't think
they're gonna watch it I don't think
they're gonna like it no they certainly
watch Barbie look Tommy hey Ian thanks
so much on that we're going to stay with
the topic of movies in Hollywood now but
talk about a different film
another film causing a bit of
controversy do stay with us both of you
this week is Bradley Cooper's Maestro in
it the non-jewish actor plays composer
Leonard Bernstein who was Jewish with
the aid of a prosthetic nose now critics
say it amounts to do face and the only
Jewish actors should play Jewish
characters to talk more about this let's
bring in former senior Rabbi to Reform
Judaism lauriana klausner thank you very
much for making time for us it's a
sensitive issue this once I'm really
pleased you could speak to us on this
um a lot of people saying this is
totally wrong that Bradley Cooper is
wearing a prosthesis for this film and
he shouldn't be cast because he's not
Jewish what do you think
I think they're two separate issues he's
gone for I think it's absolutely fine
he's gone for authenticity
and actually Leonard Bernstein had a
very long nose if I just thought I'd do
a profile of myself I have quite a
distinctive profile if someone in my
fantasy were to ever be me they would
need to put on an extra nose or if I saw
a kitty nose I'd be thinking something
is wrong here so I think it's fine that
they've gone for authenticity and the
family said yes our dad did have a big
nice nose so I don't think it has to be
anti-semitic at all and it is a separate
issue from where the Jews have to act
Jews and I do also not think that Jews
need to act Jews because I want actors
to imagine and identify what's it like
to be that person and I do not think
that Jews have to act Jews because I
really want under other people to
understand what it's like being Jewish
um somebody that doesn't agree is David
bediel a famous comedian here in the UK
of course he said another day another
film TV show Playing which a famous Jew
is played by non-jew I have talked and
written about this many times about how
it's a question of not acting but of
context minority casting being presently
dominated by the notion of authenticity
the question is why that doesn't apply
to Jews and what that means for how
people see Jews what did you make of
those comments
well I think David is brilliant
um and his book is fantastic on
anti-Semitism but I don't agree with him
on the acting thing and we've actually
disagreed on this before uh because I
think that if someone is a great actor
part of the greatness is to act
something different and being Jewish is
very different than pretending to be a
person of color or a different sexuality
um so I think it's absolutely fine and
it seems to me he's done a beautiful job
and the family of Leonard Bernstein has
a Jamie Alexander and Nina Bernstein
said that Bradley Cooper involved the
three of them along every step of the
amazing journey they fully support the
uh the film and the way it's been done
as well they don't want to see any
misrepresentations or misunderstandings
of the efforts coming to you Ian do you
think people will look past this or in
fact whether it will play into the box
office success of this film
I I don't really see it having much of
an impact at the box office I look we we
have seen people of various ethnic and
religious backgrounds play every sort of
role possible certainly lots of Jewish
actors have played uh people of other
religions and ethnicities over the years
uh this to me seems like a controversy
that's uh that's misplaced and and you
know prosthetic noses uh on on character
roles those happen all the time it it
helps you distance yourself from the
fact that you're watching Bradley Cooper
I think people are going to judge the
film on its own merits and I think
that'll determine its Commercial Success
tell me any thoughts
yeah it sounds like we're all in
agreement so this is a wonderful day you
know I agree wholeheartedly there's a
reason why it's called acting because
people are not themselves they play
other people they play other characters
in other scenarios and other walks of
life and that is the point of acting so
I think this is a lot of faux outrage
and I agree with the previous
commentators I see no issue with this I
think it's people splitting hairs
looking for something to be offended and
outraged by and as you said misplaced
anger here let's just enjoy art for what
it is we don't need to nitpick every
little part of it and try to be offended
by things that really are not meant to
be offensive and they're not designed to
be offensive and most people probably
wouldn't find offensive uh Rabbi Laura
sorry you wanted to add something
well I think it's worth thinking about
two things one is what's the distress
and there is a serious distress that
there is still anti-judge hatred but
most importantly if you assume good
intent if you assume that someone's
saying something or asking something
that you might find problematic as a
Jewish person you pointed out the vast
majority of people say oh I didn't
realize
because actually most people either
don't care about people being Jewish or
queer quite interesting really
rabba Laura really interesting last
points Tommy and Ian thank you to
interesting segment there on Hollywood
and are we gonna go watch those movies I
think the box office will have the
answered uncensored next tonight vegans
are calling for Prince William to help
incentivize their quote plant-powered
Revolution should the next king give
Royal approval to a way of life that
some are saying could seriously damage
the livelihoods of our Farmers we're
going to be debating that next
[Music]
good evening I'm Piers Morgan uncensored
in New York City yeah King peers and
King Q I think it's only one for one
king
he's mocked your weight Trump yeah look
at him fail stop working just because
their skin folk don't mean they're
kinfolks do you believe you can win this
he's making me cry again I'm trying to
force you out yes I feel betrayed keep
it award-winning
key Edwards has been revealed as the
presenter at the center of the BBC
Scandal he is the most important
television presenter on the BBC that we
pay for whatever torture he may have
been going through in that in some way
is an excuse yeah for at what appear
an abuse of power when they first got
together there were press stories
weighty Katie that would make her a
better princess of wealth because you're
not just marrying the man you're
marrying the job that resonates with
people Elaine Maxwell agreed to be
interviewed for the very first time I
obviously wish I'd never met him
the conservative party can certainly win
the next election yes
did he say yes I have taken drugs and
they bent the rules or lied on the visa
application form and therefore got it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has risen to 1522 and may God
rest your souls
let it roll
[Music]
juicing oil the knock-on effect is far
larger than just CO2 I nearly have
empathy when I'm speaking to them I know
you're probably going to vote me off
shorts
some of them they're easily lit
you can kiss my American Air thank you
very much very nice of you
Twitter you Sons can you please
reinstate my account thank you that's
the threat that you'd be worried about
so are you saying that you're being
overwhelmed that you're inundated we are
really working hard for you we're just
asking patients to be patient with us
what does a woman make
you weren't asked to give evidence to
the grand jury I'm the only one that has
Battalion materials you don't drink
never taken drug you're stinking Rich
should you be concerned
if it's on your mind it's on talk TV
it's about you and your opinions if
you're thinking about it we're talking
about it
it's all about me that's a joke
[Music]
this is talk TV
welcome back to uncensored now
celebrities have today signed an open
letter asking Prince William to use his
climate change awards they're called the
Earth shot prize to incentivize a
plant-powered Revolution by adding a
special vegan category now A-list is
signing that letter include Olivia
Coleman Sharon Osborne our very own and
Dame Emma Thompson they've said the vote
preservation of the planet is at stake
critics however warn that a rapid shift
to plant-based foodstuffs could have
devastating effects for the rural
economy so should the Future King give
his Royal approval to veganism or is
this something he should just stay clear
of joining me to discuss all this
YouTube stars and best-selling vegan
authors Henry Firth and Ian thiesby also
known as the Bosch boys and from Wales
the farmer Gareth Wynne Jones also joins
us Gareth as you're sitting there very
kindly for us this evening thank you I
will start with you
um start off by telling us a little bit
about what you farm
yeah so um where the beef and sheep
operation up on the cardinali mountain
range my family's been on the same land
for 375 years
producing food in a very sustainable
regenerative and
um ethical way okay
um so what do you make of this idea that
the Prince of Wales is being sort of
pressured to kind of lean more into
veganism and make it one of the Staples
of his sort of awards of green economy I
mean do you think that veganism poses a
threat to Farmers like you
not really no that about three percent
of the population and we can see a lot
of the businesses dropping off a a cliff
just look at some of the you know the
shares in things like beyond meat and uh
oat milk or Oakley whatever they are uh
yeah it's a joke people are starting to
find uh the truth about all this
processed rubbish and um it's it's you
know real food balanced Food Eat local
eat seasonal uh sustainable and food
that's produced in a regenerative way
it's easy
now you're talking about some of those
processed um companies you know we've
talked about it on the show before the
vegan bubble whether or not it's
bursting companies like beyond meat uh
only other companies like that but
there's other ways to be vegan aren't
they you don't have to eat the processed
stuff you can eat just some soybeans and
some carrots if you want to
yeah that's not a problem carry on but
they will need the farmer every day
every vegan will need a farmer you know
um doesn't matter what your diet is you
are going to need a farmer I think we
have to look at where we live our
climate we've got a great temperate
climate in this country and you know
we've got a lot of marginal land which
is great for growing grass to produce
fantastic protein that comes from beef
and lamb and you know that's the same
sensible option for them together as we
have been since day dot and you know
what if you want to be vegan if you want
to be vegetarian pescatarian flexitarian
Carnival that's a personal choice I I
will never ever take that away from
anybody but don't mislead people to
believe that you're going to save the
planet on a vegan diet because that's
rubbish and I will tell you as a farmer
that grows the majority of the food to
feed my family I know that a lot more
creatures will die for me to get my veg
and salad on my plate than me to get my
meat why why is that why will more
creatures die Gareth in your mind
well how much of your own food have you
ever grown very very little I grow
tomatoes and chillies in my garden
bye so every time we're growing a
carrots our peas we'll be able to
protect them from our squirrels our mice
the insect life there will be thousands
of creatures dying for us to get the veg
and to get the salads onto our plates
but you kill one cow and that will feed
many families for many months so the
best ethical way you know to be vegan is
to kill a cow you know
eat a plant-based diet let me finish eat
a plant-based diet because that cow was
eating nothing but grass and stick it in
your freezer and that will have the less
death toll than you can ever have with
anything else
um astonishing uh statement that I want
to come to our boys in the studio to
respond on that Henry and Ian the Bosch
boys you're listening to that there uh
where hunter gatherers I must disguise
I'm a meat eater I'm happy to eat vegan
and vegetarian food as well but I am a
carnivore as well uh
killing a cow kinda did you what do you
make of that I mean I think we heard um
we heard a load of anecdotes there so
it's it's great to hear from a farmer
and you're right every vegan does need a
farmer and of course like we even Ian's
family were farmers so we don't
necessarily have anything against
Farmers but the problem is when you
don't look at the science and you can
say you know these random statistics
like killer cow that'll feed a family
but the reality is your farm can't feed
the United Kingdom and Farms like yours
can't feed the United Kingdom and in
fact if we expand that out to think
about the world if we want to keep
eating meat at the rate we're eating
meat today we will need 1.7 planets by
2050. there just isn't in enough land
for our current appetite to meet so we
are urging people to eat more
plant-based proteins it's a great
technology it's not dying in any way
shape or form in fact it's growing it's
kind of weird to just pull one company's
sales and use that to say that the
market has died and we should all
realize this is a wonderful new
technology and protein can come from
plants as well as from animals anything
to add yeah I mean basically my my
grandfather with grandfather was a
farmer and I recognized that he was
arguably the hardest working person that
I have ever had the fortune of coming
into contact with and you're right we do
need Farmers absolutely and our argument
isn't with the smaller farmers in Wales
who are doing like organically raised uh
beef and Cat beef and lamb our real
issue is with massive factory farms that
are basically just churning our animals
at an unsustainable level and destroying
everything in their path like that is
something that we I think we can all
agree on is just completely wrong but
also what was just mentioned is the fact
that you know the United Kingdom is a
temperate client but we should climate
but we should all be aware that we've
got a climate emergency going on right
now we're looking at one degree of
warming two degrees of warming three
degrees of warming you know we're not
far off we're getting 40 degrees
happening in summer we're not far off
moving towards a more Mediterranean
climate and you might find rather than
vegans being a threat to your Farms we
might actually find that you know the
climate is going to be a problem whether
it's wildfires whether it's different
crops won't grow on your land you won't
be able to raise sheep because it's too
warm you're actually probably going to
soggle more from the climate than from
vegans given the rather damp scrub of a
summer we've had this year a lot of
people saying ah what climate emergency
but of course there are Shores other
than the United Kingdom in South America
the class ways of forests to feed cows
you know that is one of the claims about
why we should move away from farming
Gareth I want to come back to you
because you said you didn't feel
threatened by vegans because they
represent such a small uh proportion of
sales and of food and farming in this
country but at the same time it seems
like you really don't like them
no I've got to agree with the meat vegan
in the middle sorry I'm not sure what
your name is but um you know I I agree
with you cheap food comes at a price so
cheap food comes at a price to the
environment it comes at a price to the
animal and it comes at a price to the
farmer so we need to address that one
third of the food we're producing in
this country goes into landfill so we
need to address that you know um I'm not
saying that we're perfect by a long way
but we need to be working together we
need to look at ways to find
regenerative answers to food production
we need to be look at seasonality you
know I love it you know follow follow my
page there's a million people on social
media that follow me every day I've got
790 000 followers on YouTube so you know
I'm I'm a bit of a guy on on social
media as well probably you've never
heard of me but you know
Gareth Gareth win Jones on social media
if you want to look him up and come on
let's have a let's have a YouTube on and
guys what's Nelson's most popular farmer
heads
uh well I've been called other things
but that's that's maybe coming from
another day so we thought that was
Jeremy Clarkson
hey hey everybody's got a favorite
family's done his thing but you know
he's
a newbie into the farming community and
he's doing a great job fantastic job you
know so is Caleb but I I'm trying to
tell you I have a 375 years of history
on this Farm you know I love what I do
and you boys want to come up I'll show
you I had Tim sheath up here many years
ago with country file I took him onto
this farm he was a vegan Free Runner I
took him onto the mountain I explained
to how I grow my own food you know I
I've got a little veg pots just behind
me I've got my own polytunnel I am
trying to be a self-sustained as
possible I even produce my own cider you
know I'm trying to bring things back to
normality so people can enjoy food and
and I don't care what your diet is if
people think I hate vegans that's that's
rubbish but what I do hate is the
misleading propaganda we need to work
together boys we need to bring that
Collective together and we can eat meat
we can do it in a regenerative and
sustainable way and we need the these
ruminants to produce the Fantastic soil
to grow your vegetables as well so we
need to work together so obviously we're
not Farmers but we do understand and you
know we want to work together and we
want to we want to find the right answer
for the United Kingdom I guess one of
the things we don't want to miss though
is the science and if you look at Joseph
Paul's study at Oxford University you do
see that regardless of where the meat
was formed it is more polluting it gives
off more CO2 than any plant food and
we've just got to bear that in mind so
we're not urging everyone to go vegan
but we are urging everybody to
understand the truth
it is going to be a more polluting
Choice which you are free to make yeah
Gareth you can quickly give a response
to running short time go on listen
you're misleading people it's a cycle
okay it's Oxford University study no no
no listen Oxford University comes State
Oxford University Oxford University but
that studies up their backside because I
have understood a lot more about that
carbon cycle and what it's done and you
know have a look at what the Bannerman
Project's doing down in Caldwell they're
catching the methane from cows do and
they're putting it into a tractor they
are going off-grid by using that me
thing there's a lot of Technology out
there that Oxford University it depends
who pays the bills and who is putting
money into that research I look I'm a
farmer I've got money in this game I
want my children to do what I'm doing
for the Next Generation I'm not
disputing that there's problems but
Oxford University have got this from
livestock and farmers are part of the
solution and if we don't work together
and if you keep pointing fingers we are
going to be sleepwalking into food
shortages you are going to need a farmer
every single day of your life doesn't
matter where you live in the world we
you had your chance to uh rebut that
there the Oxford University report guys
look it's been great having you all on
and we've heard about Garrett's YouTube
channel you've got a YouTube channel too
the boss boys they've got a book out
today as well Bosch me there you go it's
a bit of a plug for you and thank you
all very much for coming in for that
debate uncensored next tonight we pay
tribute to veteran broadcaster and the
king of British chat show so Michael
Parkinson who sadly passed away at the
age of 88.
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
coming up on the talk the education
secretary says a level grades are back
to normal as tens of thousands miss out
on top marks on results day prime
minister Rishi sunak backs away calls to
put the government's Net Zero policy to
a public vote and we'll be remembering
iconic broadcaster Sir Michael Parkinson
that's all at nine o'clock
[Music]
today we learned the sad news of the
passing of TV Legends Sir Michael
Parkinson the legendary pop broadcaster
and King of the chat show he interviewed
over get this 2 000 guests over a
50-year career let's take a look at some
of those most memorable moments
you feel that David is perhaps better as
a better public Persona I call them
Golden Balls you know
boys used to come and practice kissing
on me
even the angels
if all the black angels they took the
pictures
thank you
are back with me to remember the TV
Legend I'm joined Again by my Pat Paula
Isabel and Richard all three of you
thank you oh you know we're all smiling
during that he was a star he uh passed
away 88 years old today surrounded by
Family he had such a long career I can't
believe how many interviews he did and
one of the common refrains I'm seeing
people say about him which I would agree
with is he always made it about his
guests rather than about himself
absolutely when I was thinking about him
today
um there were two points and actually
you've shown both of them that even rod
and emu which was my childhood
um and then the Muhammad Ali interview
so as a child I remember the rod in emu
um I'm sat and watched that and just was
just I'm shocked it was like horrifying
it was like rolling around on the floor
and that you know you just didn't do
that in those days on TV and then as an
adult I watched the Muhammad Ali
interview and understood as an adult how
important that interview was so he was
able to to reach a child at the same
time also able to reach an adult and
that is quite impressive as a presenter
to do Isabel favorite interview
um I really like the Ali G one where I
mean Sasha Baron Cohen where you know
he's in character and somehow to pull
that off is quite difficult isn't it you
know and a lot of actors do do this
they'll go into other characters while
they're being interviewed when the
interview's actually about themselves
not their character but he handled that
so deftly and it was really funny I mean
you probably can't play clips of it now
because some of it is a little bit edgy
I think we could say yeah for me it was
actually the Dame Edna average interview
with uh Dame Julie gents Dench and our
own Sharon Osborne uh back in 2004 which
I watched again today and it was just
absolutely hysterical and in true Dame
Edna style she she he took over the
interview and became the interviewer and
we started interviewing Parky and but
that was part of his success wasn't it
it was it was sort of giving uh giving
the floor to the guest and and really
letting them just uh just come out and
and just go phrase and he was he had a
very subtle style
it was it was just very clever very
engaging and okay there were less TV
stations then
um but the you know the the audiences
were millions and millions and you know
people would would literally leave the
pub to get home early to watch Parky you
know it was that significant appointment
television he was warm he was relatable
he was smart he knew his guess well you
know who did one of his later interviews
for Piers Morgan take a look
I love my father my father the best man
I ever met and he said to me one day he
said you know you've had a good life in
London you I said I'm done he said in
the email Bobby too I said that's true
he said he meant to do some fantastic
people some beautiful women but it's not
like playing Cricket the Yorkshire
right isn't it she
did Paula
well do you know what I was going to say
I was going to stick my neck out here
and the most beautiful Accent on TV and
we don't get enough of the accents on TV
um and I think that was part of the
attraction for him he wasn't just this
London presenter he was able to connect
with the whole of the country wasn't he
um will we see him again I don't know
no somebody knew somebody different is
going to have to come along
um but will his shoes ever be filled no
are you saying this studio here with
four British Southern British London
sounding broadcasters is not and and
there it isn't it and there it is his
very own Piers Morgan I think is
absolutely on every day a substitute you
know what
um I mean he learns the big interviews
too we're looking for a new king aren't
we we're looking for a new king I just
think of peer's idea I just think it's a
bit early to to suggest that you know
it's like when we lost Cilla Black yeah
there was just nobody no that's true
wasn't it there was just nobody that you
could think of who was going to be able
to fill her shoes and I guess the
world's a more sort of divisive place
where there's more seems to be more
controversy he was able to conduct his
interviews in a
it was just in a more even-handed gentle
way and I'm not sure we quite have that
that level of of gentle approach in in
the interviews I mean someone will tell
me I've missed out X or Y but you get
the point that is all
it's uncensored good night
[Music]
foreign
Trump yeah look at him fail stop working
just because their skin folk don't mean
they're kinfolks do you believe you can
win this but he's making me cry again
I'm trying to force you out yes I feel
betrayed keep it award-winning
Hugh Edwards has been revealed as the
presenter at the center of the BBC
Scandal he is the most important
television presenter on the BBC that we
pay for whatever torture he may have
been going through in that in some way
is an excuse yeah for what appears to be
an abuse of power when they first got
together there were press stories
weighty Katie that would make her a
better princess of wealth because you're
not just marrying the man you're
marrying the job that resonates with
people Elaine Maxwell agreed to be
interviewed for the very first time I
obviously wish I'd never met him
the concelli party can certainly win the
next election can we yes
did you say yes I have taken drugs and
they bent the rules or lied on the visa
application form and therefore got it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy